[Music]
on this saturday night canadians stuck
in afghanistan
stand here stay there crowds and chaos
at kabul's airport is preventing
families from getting out safely
the view from the ground and the
government's response
the conservatives carbon tax as the
election campaign concludes its first
week are the blue tories going green
vaccinated and infected why so-called
breakthrough cases of covid19 are on the
rise
and who will carry canada's flag at the
paralympic games i really hope that for
the kids
living with disabilities this inspires
them
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight jeff semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight in afghanistan and
the scramble to get canadians and some
afghans out of the country the federal
government now confirms that a second
canadian flight left kabul yesterday it
was carrying 106 afghans bound for
resettlement in canada and an
unspecified number of allied service
members ottawa says it will continue
with that rescue mission as long as the
airport remains under allied control
and this is what that airport looks like
today chaos and confusion as thousands
of people desperately try to leave
afghanistan nato says at least 12 people
have been killed in and around that
airport since sunday when the taliban
took control of the capital hundreds of
canadians and afghans with ties to
canada are believed to be stuck in
afghanistan right now including fahima
fakiri global affairs canada told her
and her three young children who are
canadian citizens to go to the airport
yesterday but when she arrived she told
me and farsi they couldn't make it
through the chaotic crowd
uh
is
[Music]
and i'm joined now by fahima's stepson
meiwan fakiri he's in kitchener ontario
and has been in contact with canadian
government officials trying to get his
family out of kabul safely so meiwan
thank you for joining us what has the
communication and correspondence been
like with the canadian government what
have you heard
when we got in touch with global affairs
canada they put us on a priority list to
be evacuated
for the four of them especially since
they were children
they let us know that we'd have 24 hours
notice before the flight would take off
for them to go straight to the airport
and make it in
we were actually given two and a half
hours notice uh we quickly mobilized
them it was about four a.m for them back
home
they went to the airport and they were
advised to go to the north gate after
calling back to global affairs canada
they let us know we actually made a
mistake there's an outbreak or there's
fighting happening at the north gate
please go to the east gate instead which
caused another delay and later on we
learned that they actually made a
mistake and the flight was arriving in
two and a half hours
for them to board and it would leave
some time afterwards and that put him in
a chaotic situation with added stress to
try to make it through the crowd which
was impossible at the time
and so where do things stand tonight
then
we let them know that it's impossible to
expect these children under the age of
10 and their mom to power through this
crowd
and put their lives at risk and they let
us know that their hands are tied and
they will be able to be evacuated once
they get to the gate and inside of the
airport and not before
and there's nothing that they can do to
expedite the process or try to find a
creative solution to get them into the
airport in another way
right and what's your response to that
what's your message to the canadian
government trudeau made a commitment and
the canadian government made a
commitment to canadian citizens and to
our allies in afghanistan to take them
out and to bring them to safety and the
reality on the ground right now is that
there is no leadership no organization
no clear strategy in place to actually
have them evacuated and we're losing
hope
that's meiwan fakiri whose family is
stuck in afghanistan tonight meiwan
thanks for joining us take care
and the canadian government has faced a
lot of criticism like that this week for
its efforts to rescue canadians in
afghanistan and bring afghan
interpreters to canada mercedes
stevenson interviewed the minister of
immigration for the west block which is
back on the air this sunday and
throughout the election campaign and she
joins us now from ottawa with a preview
mercedes
good evening jeff
thanks for having me uh you know a lot
of questions for canadians about what
exactly is happening on the ground in
afghanistan and i've been speaking to a
number of interpreters as well as
canadian citizens and canadian permanent
residents who are trying to get to the
airport like the mother you just spoke
to and her family and there's been a lot
of criticism of the canadian
government's performance on this file
while other countries have sent out
their special forces like the french or
the british to actually retrieve people
and bring them through those dangerous
taliban checkpoints and all of those big
crowds around the airport to the safety
of the plane canada has essentially been
telling people to show up at the airport
try to make their way through the gate
yell canada or wear red
and that they'll be let in but a lot of
folks are having trouble making it
through onto those flights i asked the
immigration minister whether or not
canada would consider doing something
similar and sending our special forces
out to retrieve people and bring them to
the plane this is what he told me
we do have flights running again that's
good uh we are participating in an air
bridge with our coalition forces that's
good that's going to increase our
capacity potentially to get some other
canadian bound afghans out as well and
we are going to continue to make sure
that we process all of this as quickly
as possible cutting through the red tape
the bottom line is we'll do whatever it
takes to get as many people out as
quickly as possible
and so jeff the question really is now
what does that mean what will that
actually look like the government's been
trying to get rid of some of the red
tape requirements like filling out forms
at an internet cafe to speed this up but
there's only been a couple of flights so
far out of kabul other countries have
had many more now they say people will
be able to get on allied flights but
there's still a lot of questions about
just how many canadians and afghans the
government will be able to rescue before
the airfield is no longer held and no
longer safe
okay and i know you'll have more on this
tomorrow on the west block mercedes
stephenson in ottawa thanks
and the u.s embassy meanwhile is warning
americans and afghans whom they've
promised to help to stay away from that
airport they're growing security
concerns about the risks outside the
gates including possible threats from
the so-called islamic state jennifer
johnson has the
latest chaotic scenes outside the kabul
airport as tens of thousands of
americans and afghans remain trapped
many so desperate they're breathing
gunfire and climbing over razor wire
fences to get inside stay there stand
out the u.s embassy is warning people
not to come to the airport without
approval from a u.s government
representative because of security
threats including from the so-called
islamic state as you can see this is a
very complex and multi-step
operation once inside the airport
thousands are boarding planes to escape
the country as taliban soldiers marched
through the streets of kabul in full
military gear heartbreaking for so many
who hoped for a better life in this
country including gina abbawi an afghan
american from virginia who returned to
her homeland six years ago to teach it
was a dream come true for me i got a
little house by the mountains and it was
really cool and it's the saddest day of
my life right now
i just cannot imagine leaving but
unfortunately
it's time to go
with few possessions in hand afghan
residents who aided the u.s and its
allies are now refugees arriving in
dozens of countries around the world but
grateful to get out alive they are
in good condition they look very
exhausted
they look very tired but
seeing the children
and the families coming off with huge
smiles it warms your heart u.s president
joe biden who is getting daily briefings
from his national security team is
pledging the military will get out any
american who wants to leave afghanistan
but pentagon officials admit the window
of opportunity is shrinking we're
fighting against both time and space
that's the race that we're in right now
and um
and we're trying to do this as quickly
and as safely as possible more than 13
000 americans and afghans have been
airlifted out this week but tens of
thousands remain in a country now under
strict taliban militant rule
fearing every day they stay here could
be their last
jennifer johnson global news washington
to the election now and liberal leader
justin trudeau took a day off from the
campaign trail while the conservatives
are in western canada this weekend
shoring up support in provinces where
they traditionally perform very well but
aaron o'toole is branding himself as a
different kind of conservative leader
and part of his platform is proving a
tough sell to some voters in the west
abigail beeman is traveling with aaron
o'toole's campaign so abigail what are
voters there saying about the
conservatives carbon pricing plan
jeff aaron o'toole hasn't had a lot of
in-person events with voters but at a
rally with supporters in saskatoon one
man was very clear telling o'toole he
wasn't pleased he flip-flopped on a
carbon tax and that a lot of farmers are
quote pissed off so we asked o'toole
about his message to both those
saskatchewan farmers and voters in oil
rich alberta and whether he's worried
about their support going somewhere else
i've put forward a plan to the provinces
that can help us achieve that
it does price carbon and i do get some
questions about it and sometimes
sometimes some people frustrated about
that but it shows my commitment and by
the time i finished that conversation
they understood we need to get the
country working again
it wasn't so clear whether that
particular voter bought the argument i
tried to speak to him afterwards and he
said he wasn't comfortable discussing it
o'toole pitches his plan as one that
will meet the paris climate commitments
while pricing carbon to a maximum of 50
dollars a ton much less than the liberal
plan but certainly there is a disconnect
among conservative supporters about a
carbon tax and not just farmers or those
in the oil and gas sector at the party's
last convention members voted against a
resolution that included the phrase
climate change is real and while aaron
o'toole wants to be a progressive leader
with a climate change policy he also has
to work to not alienate those among his
base
the liberals were completely shut out of
alberta and saskatchewan in the 2019
election but the conservatives do face
competition from both the liberals and
ndp including here in edmonton jeff
thanks abigail
ndp leader jagmeet singh says his party
if elected will make housing more
affordable for canadians singh says he
wants to build half a million affordable
homes over the next decade and he's also
promising rental supports for families
michael couture is traveling with the
singh campaign and has a breakdown of
the ndp's housing pitch
for some families living in big cities
home ownership is impossible
in places like toronto even renting can
be too expensive for working couples
i saw about
16 places
and we finally got one
right downtown and like i was saying we
pay 2500 all together and we thought
that that was like a good deal thinking
2500 dollars a month is a good deal is
the problem according to ndp leader jug
meet singh he claims rental prices have
risen four thousand dollars per year
since the liberals took power and singh
says it's because of certain loopholes
he plans to close
the cmhc is being used right now by
large corporations
to to get cmhc backed loans that allow
them to purchase buildings and units
that they then renovate and effectively
renovate their
their occupants
singh is also promising to hand out up
to five thousand dollars a year in
rental supports for families
the liberals haven't released their full
housing platform yet but the spring
budget built on the 2017 strategy with a
2.5 billion dollar commitment to create
thirty five hundred affordable housing
units the ndp is pledging to build five
hundred thousand affordable homes within
ten years while the conservatives plan
is to build one million homes over three
years but nothing specific on affordable
units we fought for people in the
pandemic and we're going to fight for
people in the recovery
the affordable homes singh is promising
would likely be built by those same
developers the ndp says are taking
advantage of cmhc loopholes when pressed
on that point
singh softened his language somewhat we
know we'll have to work with private
developers but we want to make sure that
the priority is not on those developers
it's on people and we can incentivize
and encourage developers to work in a
way that actually benefits canadians
sunday will be a little more somber for
singh he's scheduled to attend just one
event in the morning where he'll help to
mark the 10-year anniversary of the
passing of former mvp leader jack layton
jeff mike look at her in toronto thanks
mike jugmeet singh and the four other
national party leaders will square off
in a debate in both english and french
early next month but one face that you
will not see on the stage this time
around is people's party of canada
leader maxine bernier the leaders
debates commission confirmed today that
bernie's party did not meet its criteria
the ppc didn't win a single seat in the
last election despite running candidates
in every single riding across the
country the party that bernier founded
received just 1.6 of the vote that's
below the 4 threshold and recent opinion
polls suggest its national support
remains below 4
the french debate will be on september
the 8th at 8 pm eastern and the english
program will air september 9th at 9 pm
eastern both will be at the canadian
museum of history in gatineau quebec
still ahead the race for 24 sussex one
week into the election campaign who
appears the most popular potential prime
minister
plus breakthrough infections what are
the chances of a fully vaccinated
canadian catching covid19
welcome back liberal leader justin
trudeau wrapped up the first week of the
federal election campaign with a clear
advantage according to new polling from
ipsos canadians trust the incumbent
liberals on three of the top five
election issues health care the pandemic
and climate change the conservatives and
leader aaron o'toole are trusted most on
the economy while jugg jugmeat sings ndp
has the edge when it comes to the issue
of affordability with a campaign lasting
just five weeks there's only a brief
window for opposition leaders to
persuade voters it's time for a change
eric sorenson has more
justin trudeau began the election
campaign with a head start his presence
for 18 months during the pandemic all
but shut out the opposition leaders on
the national stage he's just better
known than his political rivals i'm
asking you to stand with us
vote for real ambitious leadership it
shows in polling by ipsos as the
election kicked off trudeau was seen as
the best candidate for prime minister by
39 percent of canadians well ahead of
conservative leader aaron o'toole at 25
percent and jagmeet singh at 23.
compared with voter intentions trudeau
runs slightly ahead of his party as does
singh o'toole lags a little behind the
conservative brand as the campaign
kicked off the incumbent prime
minister's always in polling i've been
doing this for about 30 years always
have an advantage whenever you ask
anything about leadership canada's
conservatives will stand with those who
suffered during the downturn an election
campaign though helps to level the
playing field the opposition in
particular o'toole and singh are now
getting more media coverage and a closer
look from canadians at their plans for
the country while justin trudeau has
made a lot of announcements and done a
lot for show it really hasn't improved
people's lives a big part of what this
campaign is going to be about is
building familiarity for the new
opposition party leader um aaron o'toole
and for singh he's still got a lot of
blanks to fill in for the canadian
public as well
incumbency however is a two-edged sword
familiarity can breed trust for some
voters and mistrust for others
assessing party leader attributes
trudeau leads the others on who
canadians think will keep their election
promises and who's best to manage during
tough economic times but he also leads
as the party leader more canadians think
has a hidden agenda and the one who will
say anything to get elected
[Applause]
so the opposition chips away at the
front runner has he done anything he's
been in power for six years if the
numbers don't move during the course of
the campaign then the opposition parties
haven't done their job it is a steep
climb for opposition leaders who've been
largely sidelined by the pandemic to
present themselves and their platforms
they have barely four weeks left to
become better known and trusted by
canadian voters eric sorensen global
news toronto
still ahead a fully vaccinated toronto
woman's battle with covid19
you're watching global national
welcome back even if you're double
vaccinated that doesn't mean you're not
at risk of catching covid19 so-called
breakthrough cases are on the rise as
canada faces a fourth wave and experts
warn those cases will grow as the delta
variant surges but there's also some
good news jamie morocco explains
when janice singer returned from a trip
to mexico she says she didn't feel very
well imagine if you were to have like a
regular bold that's very light but a
test at pearson international airport
confirmed it wasn't a common cold the
double vaccinated torontonian caught it
was coveted 19. i got the vaccine and
then i went to a place that had very
very high
covet transmission
and i did nothing to protect myself
health experts say the highly
transmissible delta variant is making
breakthrough cases like singers more
common we see more and more people that
they are even with two vaccines uh even
talking about pfizer
they can be vaccinated
infected and also they can transmit the
disease by the end of july in ontario
for example out of roughly 8.5 million
fully vaccinated people nearly 2 000
were infected with covid19
and in iceland a shining example of
vaccination rates at 70 of its total
population fully inoculated between
mid-july and early august 77 of
infections were in people who were fully
vaccinated the silver lining almost all
had mild symptoms the vaccines prevent
you from getting disease they don't make
you impervious to infections infectious
disease expert donald vince says the
lack of severe outcome is why
vaccinations are so important your body
will be able to respond to that
infection and neutralize the virus much
sooner than somebody who's not
vaccinated and why singer is relieved
she got the shot a hundred percent i'm
happy that i got vaccinated new data out
of the u.s this week revealed certain
covet 19 shots don't offer long-term
protection and why health officials
there are recommending boosters for all
american adults here health experts say
we should stay focused on cobit 19
safety measures at least until globally
vaccination rates rise jamie morocco
global news toronto
congratulations priscilla garnier next
meet the woman chosen to lead team
canada into the tokyo paralympic games
[Music]
welcome back the paralympic flame has
now been lit in tokyo and ahead of the
opening ceremony team canada has just
revealed who will carry the country's
flag
it's been my dream to compete in the
paralympics ever since i was a
ten-year-old child and to be given the
honor of flagra is beyond anything i
could have imagined i really hope that
for the kids
living with disabilities this inspires
them to never stop dreaming to never
listen to somebody who tells them no and
to stand together with people who
believe in them their fellow
paralympians
that's pera judo champion priscilla
gagne the 35 year old from sarnia
ontario ranks number two in the world in
women's 52 kilograms this is her second
paralympics she's hoping to beat her
fifth place finish from rio back in
2016. the opening ceremonies kick off on
tuesday congratulations and that is
global national for this saturday night
i'm jeff semple tonight your canada is
the city of new westminster british
columbia
i'll be back here with you tomorrow have
a great night
[Music]
you